-You look stunning as always.
This is your fifth time
on the show,
and you missed
the whole Zoom period.
So we've only had you in person,
and I'm so grateful for that.
-Lucky me.
-Lucky us.
So, this is so --
this must be so exciting.
And I want to talk about
your history with Aretha,
because you have some,
which is really cool,
including she came to see you
in "The Color Purple."
-She did.
-You knew.
Your co-stars,
Cynthia Erivo, Danielle Brooks,
and others, they didn't know,
and you chose not to tell them.
You had the power to give
this information to them.
Was it just that
you didn't want them
to be in their head
during the show?
-Well, yeah, because a lot
of times when you're doing
a live show,
you kind of don't want to know
who's in the audience.
-Sure.
-And who gonna be able
to perform
and Aretha Franklin
is in the audience?
I was like,
"I'm not going to tell them.
I'm gonna wait,"
and then I'm glad I did
because all of them were like,
"I'm so glad you didn't tell us
that she was here."
I was the only one that knew.
Yeah.
-It's a lot -- You're right.
It's a lot to know,
because as an actor,
you know, you want to
embody your character.
But if that character knows
Aretha is in the house,
they're gonna be different too.
-Nobody would be able
to do nothing.
So I was like, "I don't want to
crash the show tonight.
I'm not going to tell them."
-And is she the kind of person
when she comes to the show,
that everyone --
she sticks around after?
Did people get a chance
to say hello?
-She did.
I got to introduce her
to the entire cast.
Danielle got to meet her,
Cynthia got --
the entire cast got to meet her,
and she was so gracious
to just, you know,
take photos with everyone.
Everybody was like, I mean,
people who I didn't even know
was in the house
came down to meet Aretha.
-Yeah. We were lucky enough
to have her here once,
and I feel as though
you can't --
you know, I had a little bit of
time with her.
And I feel like I didn't
get enough out of it
because at the same time,
it's like talking to someone --
she feels like, not -- you know,
I don't mean to say that --
she was, like, special
in a way that you forgot
that she could answer questions
and talk.
I just thought I would
just look at her.
And then I realized I was
making a fool out of myself.
-I kind of felt the same way.
-Yeah.
-Like, okay, this is --
like, how do you engage with
the Queen of Soul?
-Exactly.
-What do you say?
-Well, so, you had
a unique situation,
which is she hand-picked you --
-She did.
-So you at least --
I don't know.
When you got to be with her,
you were allowed to ask
questions, right?
-Y-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I guess.
I mean, but when Aretha spoke,
you just sat and you listen,
you know?
But just -- I'm still in awe
of her picking me.
What I wish I had asked is,
"Okay, why?"
You know, what would I say to
Miss Aretha Franklin?
What would you say?
I don't know.
-How did you find out that she
had thought you would be
the right person
to take this role on?
-Well, we first met
15 years ago.
This was right after I won
the Oscar for "Dreamgirls."
We met here in New York.
And she was like,
"What, you're shy or something?"
I was like, "Well, I am sitting
at the table
with Aretha Franklin.
Jesus!"
And then it wasn't until "Color
Purple" when she called me.
She said,
"Now, I've made my decision,
and it is you
who I want to play me.
Don't go and tell the pr--
Don't say a thing."
And I said, "Yes, ma'am,
I won't."
And then the next day
she went and told it.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, did you know that based on
the first time you met her?
Did you know this was something
she was thinking about?
When you first met her
15 years ago?
-Yeah. That's what
that meeting was for.
But it was just talks of it, and
there was no script at the time.
And then years later then,
she came back again,
but it was always in the back
of my mind from that moment,
so anytime -- Because I was
able to do a lot of tributes
to her throughout my career.
-Sure.
-So after a while, in my mind,
I'm like, "This is my audition."
You know?
I always had that in my mind.
-And speaking of auditions,
you did an Aretha song when you
auditioned for "American Idol."
So this was not something --
You just didn't start angling
for this late in life.
You had always been
sort of leaning on Aretha.
-Yeah. I mean, she's always
been present in my life
unconsciously in some way.
Like, even growing up in church,
I didn't realize all the songs,
the gospel songs
I grew up singing
came from her "Amazing Grace"
album.
And that was my introduction
to the world,
me on "American Idol" saying,
"Hi, my name is Jennifer Hudson,
and I'm going to sing
Aretha Franklin,
'Share Your Love with Me.'"
And now here I am.
-And did you --
So, did you open for her ever?
-I did.
-But you didn't meet her then.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Okay, hold on.
So that was before
we had our meeting.
This was right after I was
eliminated from "American Idol,"
seventh place, thank you.
-Yeah.
And it should be noted,
all the other six
are bigger stars than you.
So...
[ Laughter ]
-They're stars
in their own right.
[ Laughter ]
So, I got to open up for her.
She only allowed comedians
to open up for her.
-I didn't realize that.
-Yeah.
-So she didn't like to have
a singer before her?
-No. That's what I was told.
But she said that I could
open up for her show.
So I got to open up for her,
watch her sing,
and give her flowers.
-That's pretty good.
Now, when you put together --
do you think about the fact that
everyone who is going to
see you open
is going to see Aretha
after you,
does that affect how you put
together your run list
of the songs you're going to do,
your set list?
-It should.
[ Laughter ]
I think.
I remember her saying,
"Don't sing none of my songs."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Yes, ma'am."
But what did I even sing?
I think I sang
my own original material?
-That's good.
-But I didn't sing her song,
I'll tell you that.
-You know what?
I like two things about that.
One, first of all, I think
you would have assumed
not to sing any of her songs.
-Right.
-But do I like that Aretha knew,
"You know what?
Better safe than sorry.
I'm going to lay it out
exactly how I want it to be."
-She let me know.
-You had a pretty cool --
You did a premiere for this,
or I should say a party of sorts
out on Martha's Vineyard,
where you showed the film.
-Yes.
-And do you think
it was the kind of party --
Do you think if Aretha
could still be with us,
she would have enjoyed it?
-I think so.
They had good food.
She loved to eat.
And good music,
which was her music.
So I know she would've
loved that.
And it was a celebration of her.
So I think so.
-Was it the kind of food that
she would have liked to eat?
Did thought go into
putting together
an Aretha-friendly menu?
-I don't know if it was
an Aretha menu though.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
She would've liked some greens.
-Yeah, she would've liked
some greens.
There was another --
I don't know if you've been
reading the news.
There was another party
on Martha's Vineyard.
-It was. Were you there?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
But only -- I had a conflict,
which was I wasn't invited.
[ Laughter ]
What about you?
Were you invited?
-You know what?
I don't know if I was.
But I did sing for
Obama's 50th birthday.
-Really?
-I sure did.
-Well, I mean, I feel like
you got to get the invite
to the 60th.
Did you do one of his songs?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I sang him
"Happy Birthday" for that.
I didn't really sing much else.
But that was I guess 10 years
ago, and they did see the film.
-They did see the film?
-They did.
-How do you know they saw it?
-Because they called me
afterwards,
him and Michelle.
-Like, it wasn't like --
This was them on the phone?
-This was them on the phone.
-Gotcha.
-FaceTime, too.
-Oh, FaceTime?
-Take that!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's good 'cause, like,
a lot of people do impressions
of them.
But if it was FaceTime,
it was definitely them.
-It was them.
-That's really cool.
And also really cool,
we were talking backstage,
you're going to do a concert
at the Apollo?
-I am.
-And this is kind of --
We're in this time now
where people are getting back
in front of people again
to do their show.
You must be so excited.
-I'm so excited to just look
somebody upside the head
and sing to them
and be in the presence.
So thank you, Mastercard,
for this amazing moment.
And it's gonna be a good time.
I can't wait to sing.
I'm gonna sing
some Aretha songs.
-You're going to do some Aretha?
-If you want, you can come
and sing with me.
-I would love that.
Thank you so much.
I feel like no one ever asks.
I'll do the vowels in "Respect."
You can do --
-Can we practice?
-I would love it.
Let's practice later.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's just a delight to see you.
"Respect" is in theaters now.